well well well looks like ezra the
killer miller is back in the news but
don't worry it's not for attacking
anyone
he's learned to do it in private now
reject nation how's it going thanks so
much for clicking on this video if you
can leave a like that be i oh that's
button that's my new catchphrase moving
forward yeah
yeah it's it's not going to stick so a
couple things to talk about that all
revolve around how reportedly wb is
considering replacing ezra miller as the
flash and there's a very specific person
that they are potentially courting to
fill in the shoes for barry allen and i
also want to talk about why and uh don't
get me wrong when i say this i think he
is perfect on the show but about why i
don't think this demand for grant gustin
to replace ezra miller is the best move
moving forward but first things first i
saw this trending on twitter the best
place for all news thank you elon musk
it's being reported by screen geek now
i'm not too familiar with this outlet
that could be a crock of [ __ ] for all i
know or they can have the most insane
credibility i'm not one to speak on it
but it's being reported by them that
dylan o'brien is being courted to
replace ezra miller now i'm assuming
it's not to reshoot the flash movie but
to take over you know anything that
involves the flash whether it be solo
films or crossover appearances after
that film finally comes out in 2045. now
we've done a couple of videos talking
about the whole ezra miller situation
combined they're like 25 minutes in
total in-depth discussions one talking
about ezra's arrest the second one about
as her second arrest now personally i do
think ezra miller should be replaced i
mean yeah for ezra's own well-being as
well so ezra can take some time off
especially if ezra seems intent on never
speaking to the public about it i mean
he doesn't have to just be you know
nice to address some of this or if wb
can and for those who only focus on
ezra's mental health struggles you know
saying like this could be a robert
downey junior situation have a chance to
prove themselves that's not like a
one-to-one comparison in order for ezra
to make a comeback edward ezra would
need to you know go away for a while to
to come back and ezra clearly needs to
do some mental health healing which is a
long way to go and at this point it's
just one too many physical assaults
against women so maybe we should be more
concerned about that and them it
probably doesn't help to keep ezra and
these like major blockbusters just my
opinion we're talking more about an up
there but i'm just gonna leave it at
that for this video transition as far as
dylan o'brien goes i like this guy i
think he's a cool actor i feel like we
were just talking about how he was one
of the casting rumors for nightwing
potentially i mean i thought it'd be a
great pick for nightwing too but the
flag i could take him as the new flasher
now i haven't seen teen wolf nor have i
seen love in monsters i hear he is
fantastic in those movies but i do like
his work a lot in the maze runner i
liked his work a lot in a movie i didn't
really like a lot american assassin and
i thought he played a really funny
satirical version of himself in the
latest season of curb your enthusiasm
just that body of work alone showed me
that he could really do the action side
of being a superhero based off curb
enthusiasm he could definitely do comedy
which i think is necessary for playing
barry allen because you know i think to
play barry allen you got to have like
some comedic chops but you know i don't
i normally associate dylan o'brien as
a cool dude whereas barry allen i think
that you know unabashedly geeky socially
awkward nature to his character is so
essential to have when portraying this
person that's the end of the sentence
maybe that's some of those mannerisms
and quirks and and the other things i
haven't seen but even if he hasn't he's
clearly a skilled enough actor where i'm
sure he could pull all that off really
well so if he ends up being the
replacement i i don't think it would be
a bad choice at all i think he has the
right look for barry allen although you
know i can see you know that you know
remember like when andrew garfield was
first cast as spider-man there was that
side of the you know at least the
internet that was like too sexy for
spider-man but he was perfect it's all
about the performance at the end of the
day while i do normally associate him as
you know honk a hong kong i don't
imagine it would be the exact same
complaint and i think he's truly a
talented enough actor who can showcase a
different side that can embody barry
allen i don't want this to sound like
i'm putting down you know the looks of
gustin and ezra miller
you know he just has that kind of uh
that i wouldn't want to stand side by
side with dylan o'brien to you know
protect my own insecurities now that
being said the number one thing i am
always hearing about when it comes to
recasting ezra miller for the flashes
why don't they get grant gustin to play
him you have a perfect flash right there
i agree he is perfect in that role
absolutely perfect now admittedly i have
only seen up to the first five seasons
of the flashlight i did fall off the
show but i can't imagine he's become you
know a shitty actor in that amount of
time what we have in this version of the
you know the cinematic version of the
flash to really help distinguish this
like assuming that whoever the
replacement is if there were a
continuation of this barry allen just
with a different actor in the role i
don't really see the point because we
already seen grant gustin go on pretty
much a really long journey with the
flash i believe there's gonna be a ninth
season of this series which started off
where barry allen did not have powers
and had powers and then has had a whole
lot of life experiences and growth over
the course of the past nine years or ten
years for that matter i think i'm not
sure but it's been a long time he's been
playing the character whereas this
cinematic version of the flash even
though they are hopping too inspired by
the flashpoint story pretty early on the
character of the flash is still very
much in his early years the years that
grant gustin's portrayal has already
done
years ago he'd essentially just be
retreading territory that is already way
past with this character that's the
character's already much more mature and
then you know just the back of my point
i did screenshot one thing because you
know it's like i gotta back this up
something and i i typed in on google as
grant gustin leaving the flash but so i
found this according to deadline grant
gussen is finalizing a new contract to
return to the flash for season nine but
it would only be for one year rather
than a multi-season deal this new
contract could see the actor netting
upwards of 200 000 dollars per episode i
think he deserves more money he's the
freaking flash and he's also reportedly
capped his involvement at 15 episodes so
well that's not it exactly you know
declaration of he is leaving the flash
after a while an actor does eventually
want to give up a role they can get
tired i feel like grant custom might
want to move on to other things while
the flash movie obviously is dealing
with the multiverse inspired by
flashpoint something the show already
kind of did and wasn't the greatest and
while i think grant gustin does play a
perfect barry allen i think ultimately
it'd be him doing like a remake of it
all you know like sure a different
medium sure a different budget different
style not
exactly the same stories because there'd
be like some different execution to them
absolutely but ultimately i think it
might just cause some confusion like
they already had an episode of christ on
infinite earths where ezra met grant
they've already really made it crystal
clear that they are two separate berries
so i guess maybe if they wanted to
convert the flash show into the
cinematic version of the flash like
continue the story of the show but in in
the movies by picking up where the
series left off although i then i think
you might you know segregate some
audiences because they're racist i'm
gonna leave some audiences feeling a
little left out because i feel like a
lot of people have probably not seen all
the seasons of the flash i'm sure they
could play some catch up for the
audience but ultimately could leave
people feeling like a little bit left
out and feeling like maybe they should
have watched the show before watching
that you know what i mean i just feel
like it might create a little bit more
problems than necessary in my
perspective it feels like it might be
better just to keep it you know clearly
distinguished and separate uh just for
the storytelling and audience
association purposes but if you guys
have an idea for how it could work that
could reinvigorate grant gustin for the
role then let me know i'm open to ideas
i'm an open-minded guy i'm so
open-minded you know i was telling i'm
telling my significant other we should
be in a polyamorous relationship you
know like i could be with other girls
you could be with other girls but you
can't be with other guys
because that would make me very insecure
i don't want to deal with that level of
jealousy in my life you destroy me for
some reason i thought this would be the
right video to poke at the cliche of
majority of the polyamorous
relationships i see in los angeles
anyway guys what do you think about this
news leave your thoughts down below you
guys can subscribe and click that bell i
feel like it's kind of a weird video for
me and hey we will talk with you guys
soon